we've played five hours of God of War
Ragnarok and we're going to give you our
spoiler-free Impressions uh so I mean
let's get straight into it Tam Jake what
exactly have we played of the game yeah
so we've played the first five hours
which is what you said
um the without spoiling what happens it
is the basic intro and premise setup of
the game which is fine not to spoil
because chances are you know what that
is already if you've seen a single
trailer or even watched the even played
through the original you can probably
guess what is about to happen I think
the interesting thing is it does do
quite a lot to subvert what you think
will happen not in terms of like the
beat for beat plot but in terms of the
characters and the way they presented so
it's the very very early hours uh
character establishment a little bit of
a reminder of where they're at but in an
elegant and interesting way yeah and a
very emotional way too don't you think
Jake yes uh there is a scene very early
on that that is very sad
that has nothing to do with the story
necessarily it's just the way it's done
is very well done yeah but I think I
would say that over the whole thing is
like not only are they really hitting
those
as well it feels way funnier than the
original yeah it definitely does like
there are moments in that first five
hours where
there's comedic timing very good acting
which is surprising and people might be
thinking oh that's weird for a god of
war game where Ragnarok is coming and
Kratos has just spotted for the last
game he now knows that he's going to die
at the hands of potentially his son why
is it doing that and there is a purpose
to it and I talk about it in my written
preview we can read now on gamespot.com
but it's there to kind of show the
growth of the character as a person
there's a lot of interesting personality
changes and dynamic shifts that are
shown within the first five hours where
Kratos feels like the product of the
game that came before I think games have
a tendency to reset characters a lot
because they need to go back to the
status quo a lot and for narrative
reasons
but I was very happy to see that they
didn't do this not only is Kratos the
product of that Journey but there's also
been a lot of changes in the various
Winters that have passed since we last
saw them and the dynamic between him and
atreus is very different this time
around which they use yeah very very uh
like uh intelligently to establish
characters yeah and mimir too mimir is
with you from the start and I think
having him at the beginning just adds a
adds a little more flavor to the
conversations it's not just Kratos and
atreus having these conversations and
he's watching your back in in ways as
well I mean mimir is very much to your
point about atreus like he's very he's a
little more confident in himself he's
trying to
um assert a little bit of dominance
as to how Kratos accepts that but mimir
is very much this kind of Peacekeeper at
least at the very beginning but that
creates a really nice Dynamic where
everyone is everyone has their place in
the in the everyone has their role in it
it works really well yeah I mean is the
self-professed smartest person alive or
I guess he's alive
um and something yeah in effect he is
kind of the the media in this new family
unit that has that has come to pass like
you know Kratos and atreus to begin with
were Father and Son in perhaps name only
because of their own personality foibles
but now after the experience of the
first game they feel more like a family
unit and but they still are who they are
Kratos has a very strong-headed nature
and atreus now in his teenage years is
starting to get some of that and they
often though they don't come to like
disagreements in the time that we've
played there are some points where they
have diverging objectives or like
thoughts and the mirrors the person who
kind of steps in and is like brothers
and like it's really cute because he
calls Kratos brother and then he calls
atreus little brother so he's like the
Middle Brother which works perfectly in
this family unit where he's kind of like
the Peacekeeper and he also is like able
to be the bridge between the two of them
because when Kratos struggling to
connect with his son again mimir is the
one that's like hey maybe this is why
he's behaving this way and it helps and
the interesting thing is Kratos actually
listens yeah and like is taking advice
from mimir because they have grown a
bond and and they trust each other now
which is a very very very different
Dynamic for the ghost of Sparta who is
like a one-man operation and has been
for the longest time we talked a little
bit about uh you know story that
gameplay wise
is it just more God of War do you think
I would say so I mean there are
definitely new wrinkles to it there are
some changes but for the most part if
you played God of War 1 or 2018 rather
this game is going to feel very familiar
and tomorrow you kind of mentioned it in
your preview but I think that's by
Design I think it's supposed to feel
connected in in more ways than just the
characters yeah it's a continuation yeah
you can transition from one to the next
pretty easily and you know it's not a
bad thing because the combat in 2018 was
really good you know yeah I talked about
it in my preview again it feels like a
smart and good thing to do and the
example I use which is perhaps a bit
unfair but like it is very much a
plausible thing that could have happened
games always try and like they feel the
need to evolve and and introduce drastic
new mechanics and it can lead to like
disparity between them and in this day
and age that can be tricky you look at
something like the last of us one and
then part two and they're two very very
different games even though there are
continuation in the same way that God
avoids to Ragnarok they feel so
different that any new person coming
into him would find it jarring yeah um
whereas these two they feel cohesive and
I feel like the fundamentals not being
changed is the reason that that happens
the combat is different but it's not
drastically different there are small
things in there that kind of switch it
up a bit things like the triangle button
for example was pretty much exclusively
used to record the leviathanax in the
original but now there are unique
abilities per weapon that you can use it
like you hold down triangle with
Leviathan accent the blade part of it
with like really heavy ice
which would then be like do really heavy
damage and if you do the same with the
blades of chaos which are available from
the outset
he'll like spin it with one hand and if
you hold it down for long enough it kind
of catches fire and then he can like
summon a geyser which will launch
enemies and then there's other like
small tweaks to the way that combat
Works where you know you can now do
running jump attacks off off like
ledgers and stuff which they feel really
good they also help with like puzzle
solving as well because you can break
through flaws yeah yeah so like there's
a verticality now to the movement
because you have the blades of chaos so
you can get up above like most times in
the previous games you'd have to like
walk all the way around and get all the
way up and now it's like there's actual
grapple points that pull up and if you
run off those he'll jump and then you
can do a heavy or a light attack because
like swinging and come all the way down
which does a big big damage output but
also it's really good for like clearing
area and it makes you a little more
aware of your surroundings where you're
like I can maybe like run away here and
then get some Advantage High Ground so
yeah that's that's those are the two
main additions I think well there's also
one subtraction that I didn't think
would impact me as much as it has but I
a quick quick turn seems to be missing
or has been taken out and I'm finding
that pretty difficult like Kratos is a a
lumbering big guy and so when you see
the indicator saying that someone's
coming from behind you and you can't
immediately quick turn that took a lot
of getting used to for me honestly
um but in terms of combat itself I feel
like you wrote it in your preview the
enemies seemed to hit harder I
definitely felt like the enemies were a
little more heavy damage wise and I
think that is to kind of encourage you
to use your Parry ability a bit more and
try and manage the area around you I
think that it's also somewhat trickier
because of the lack of a quick turn I
found myself getting hit by things
behind me a lot there is a small
indicator which is like hey it's yellow
when someone's kind of got their eye on
you and they're coming at you and then
it goes red for when they're just about
to attack but In the Heat of like in the
middle of a combo where I've launched an
enemy into the air I use a trace to keep
them there switch to my fist and I'm
like in the middle of a combo like I'm
focused on timing so I'll often miss
that and they do amp up the kind of like
um awareness around uh atreus and mimir
telling you or someone's gonna attack
yeah they're really good at that to be
like hey on your left behind you that
kind of stuff but it's still like the
only way to kind of break it is to dash
out of whatever or uh yeah Dash I guess
out of whatever move you're doing
because that will cancel pretty much
every move but it kind of breaks the
flow of it um and then you kind of like
slowly turn around and then go for an
attack
yeah I I don't quite I don't think
there's anything yet that has replaced
the the input for a quick turn
um but how are you finding combat and
especially puzzles as well Jake I I
really enjoy the puzzles in these games
I think they're just difficult enough to
make me think but I usually don't get
stuck on them I will say there was one
puzzle that I did that uh no one was
giving me hints you know you've got to
try Us in the mirror with you so I was
just throwing my ax at things because
that's that's what you do in this game
and I threw it one thing and it had an
effect and atreus just said wow a lot of
good that'll do and I was like wow okay
clearly I'm doing
just to kind of wrap things up as well I
really enjoy the way it's like just like
the first game did the 2018 game funnels
you into a pretty linear section and
then it opens up and lets you do an
explore atreus will be like once you've
collected everything he goes you know I
think we got everything here and then
you'll just move on and do the next bit
and I really like the the way that it's
kind of controlling the ebb and flow of
the gameplay and just you know if I feel
like I'm maybe getting a little bit too
cramped and want to go off and do my own
thing then hey around the corner there's
this whole big area for me to explore
and so initial thoughts for me
it's great it's God of War I'm really
enjoying it I'm very excited to see
where the story goes the end point for
our preview by the way we know there's
no new footage uh that's crummy of me to
say like towards the end of the video
but uh we got into the conversation uh
we won't allowed to capture anything
from this build
um might have some new screenshots in
here don't know
um but the the place where we would
where we had to stop for this preview is
where the story like is a turn in the
story and so I'm very excited to see
where that goes yeah I'm I think it's
really good so far it seems pretty safe
which isn't necessarily a bad thing I
think a lot of that's going to come down
to the story and like we said we aren't
really going to talk about the story
here
um kind of want to you know we don't
know it we want to save that for
everyone else too but uh yeah that's
kind of the big question mark for me
like is this just gonna be another God
of War with a good story or is this just
gonna be like a you know is this gonna
blow me away like the first game did as
well yeah I think that's they're clearly
going for consistency yeah and um I mean
I'm interested to see how the story
develops it like Lucy said it's reached
the turning point now or a a major
moment um that is that is kind of poised
to change the dynamic of what's going on
but yeah at the very least like I said
it in my preview but I'm confident that
this will be a good game now I'm just
waiting to see whether it's going to be
an exceptional one like the first God of
War was well thanks boys and uh for more
on God of War Ragnarok including Tam's
review uh and we'll obviously have a
bunch more stuff going up make sure to
stay tuned to GameSpot
[Music]